lors de sa conférence de presse de fin
d'année volodimir Zelenski avait dit que
les militaires lui avaient demandé de
recruter un demi-million de soldats
supplémentaires ce que l'état-major a
ensuite démenti en disant ne pas vouloir
donner des chiffres renforçant ainsi
l'impression que personne ne veut
vraiment prendre la responsabilité d'une
décision qui risque de s'avérer
impopulaire celle d'accroître de manière
assez radicale le rythme de la
mobilisation obligatoire des Ukrainiens
mais nul ne doute que le pays a besoin
de recruter des dizaines sinon des
centaines de milliers de soldats
supplémentaires pour relever ceux qui se
battent sur le front depuis déjà près de
2 ans pour remplacer ceux qui ont été
tués ou grrièvement blessé et pour
continuer la défense du pays contre
l'agression russe alors pour mieux se
faire le gouvernement a élaboré un
projet de loi sur la mobilisation qui
vise notamment à réduire l'âge de la
mobilisation obligatoire de 27 à 25 ans
augmenter les peines les punitions pour
ceux qui chercheraient à s'en esquiver
mais aussi à limiter la durée euh du du
service militaire obligatoire à 36 mois
et en mettre en place des mesures qui
visent à mieux prendre en compte les
compétences de tel ou tel individu ce
projet de loi est sur l'ordre de jour
pour ce jeudi mais pourrait être remise
à plus tard parce que c'est une question
qui a vraiment rouvert le débat
politique en Ukraine avec des partis
d'opposition qui proposent des mesures
alternatives ou qui s'opposent à tel ou
tel aspect de ce qui est actuellement
sur la table mais pour les politologues
Ukrainiens tout rejet de ce projet de
loi pourrait être perçu comme une signe
de faiblesse non pas seulement par
Moscou mais aussi par les partenaires
occidentales de l'Ukraine que Kev veut
absolument convaincre de son unité de sa
détermination et de sa capacité à
continuer à mener cette lutte contre
l'agresseur russe